traumatismes format voyou
les constitutions donnaient peu sans intérieur
vive l'Espagne
[Musique]
quelque chose comme ça se passe bien
c'est très bien très bien
absolu les termes parce que c'est un
un peu approximatif mieux combien c'était
il n'y a pas longtemps
il parle assez bien je ne suis pas mauvais et
affaires et capitaux
la politique la plus dure
le groupe pourrait bien danser tu es le meilleur
de paris si les citoyens et
Les Parisiens décident si ce sera le prochain
maire de paris
[Applaudissements]
C'est bien
pas la jolie
il y a trop large très joli
[des rires]
parce que j'aime le tuning
parce que
à présent
très chaud dans la discothèque allons-y
la plage
on va à la plage et le soleil ne chauffe pas
mais l'Espagne merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]